hi I'm Eric Voss and my favorite comedy
show is Rick and Morty on Adult Swim and
ever since I broke down the first
episode of season 3 that was released
early I've gone back to re-watch this
series again and I've caught so many
subtle jokes that I wanted to point out
for you guys now yes the show Rick and
Morty is packed with references so I'm
gonna skip over the more obvious stuff
point out the little things that I
missed the first time that made me laugh
when I got them this time and you may
have already noticed some of these but
just just going go with it you know you
know just go with it and before I get
into these this video was brought to you
by quid now you know that thing where
you like toss a sticker onto a text
message well Quinn is an app that will
put on your phone exclusive stickers
like Rick and Morty and Breaking Bad
stuff they also have cards and 3d
figures and it's all free and we're
gonna do a giveaway of a cool-ass Rick
and Morty Funko pop vinyl figure and
I'll get to more details on that later
in the video ok so to get started the
first thing I want to point out is
Rick's burping now this isn't really a
joke but this specific style of belching
through words is actually a reference to
the old-school comedian foster Brooks he
was known from the old fire scrub roasts
thank you
as they put Frederick and gentlemen just
told you okay so with that out of the
way let's look at the first episode the
pilot one of the craziest things that
happens this episode is that a kid-free
King dies Morty's bully and summers
crush Frank now Rick freezes Frank and
he tips over and shatters and the
missing joke here is that later in the
episode to honor Frank the school flies
its flag at half-mast also in this
episode outside Beth's horse hospital
there is an early establishing shot of
doctors trying to wrangle a fussy horse
but then later in the episode they're
hosing down blood stains in the same
spot implying that this horse didn't
make it now the second episode is called
the lawn mower dog and that title is a
reference to the 1992 movie The
Lawnmower Man where a scientist gives a
mentally handicapped gardener super
intelligence which is more or less the
premise of the plot in this episode with
snuffles a dog now you may have noticed
that Rick mistakenly refers to the dog
as ruffles and ruffles is the name of
the dog in justin roiland animated
project they never completed call of dog
world's about a society of smart dogs
and one of my favorite jokes this
episode is snuffles changing his name to
snowball snuffles was my slave name you
shall now call me snowball because my
fur is pretty and white and actually
snowball was the name of the evil boss
pig in George Orwell's Animal Farm
now another inside joke that showed up
in this episode is this guy with the
rainbow suspenders and a football shirt
according to Justin roiland this
character was originally intended to be
the in universe link among Rick and
Morty and two other shows animated by
his friends Alex Hirsch who does gravity
falls and Jason Reiss who made a show
called murder police on Fox that never
aired
notice how the football on a shirt has
three Roman numerals on it 18 3 and 5
now royland said that the character
would have had different numbers on his
shirt in the other two shows and that
together that they would all form a code
with corresponding letters these numbers
correspond to are C and E but
unfortunately I never know what that
word was gonna be because the other two
animators couldn't fit him into their
shows so unfortunately this guy is just
a Rando who shows up throughout season 1
in this episode but also in the
background of clothes for counters of
the Rick kind then ranting against
trunkpeople marriage rights and Rick's T
minutes and then
leaving the party early in the season
finale and then lastly in this episode I
love this little moment when Morty
returns to his family and summer runs up
to hug him kind of motorboating him and
Morty pushes her away this is because
he's still traumatized from the dream
earlier where his sister was too sexy
okay moving on I loved all the
references in anatomy Park to things
like Jurassic Park and Disney World but
one super dark and really subtle joke
that not everyone caught but you're
honestly pretty lucky if you did miss it
came from Ethan this is summers clingy
boyfriend remember the character Jacob
counseled Ethan to help him make a
breakthrough but when you listen to what
he says closely it's pretty messed up my
brother took them fishing once in the
bushes
I can't feel like a girl yeah I'm not
gonna spell out what exactly he means by
that but I'll let you be the judge
so episode 4 that was M nights Millions
waha is also great but I want to skip
past it too my favorite episode of the
series episode 5 meeseeks and destroy'
this of course is a famous mr. meeseeks
episode also the episode of the awful
mr. jellybeans scene and I loved this
little animation detail of Rick's eyes
following mr. jellybeans as he leaves
the bathroom then back to Morty as he
puts together what might have went down
and then later in that post-credit scene
when jellybeans people learned the
horrible truth and decided to hide it
from the world notice the statue the
little boy is wearing tighty whities and
King jellybeans is doing this really
disgusted subtle lip fight I also feel
like this whole idea of letting King
jellybeans die a hero is a subtle homage
to the end of the dark night when
Commissioner Gordon decides to cover up
Harvey Dent dark side so that he can die
a martyr and inspire the people of
Gotham even the music here sounds like
it could have been composed by Hans
Zimmer wait
destroy it
[Music]
okay moving on to the next episode
episode 6 Ric potion number 9 it has a
few fun miscible jokes Mercer is this
intercom announcement from principal
vagina warning kids with the flu not to
come to the flu season dance now this of
course is a pretty dark reference to the
history of Passover where God smited
smut smooth smited the firstborn
children and the families of Egypt and
speaking of dark at the end of this
episode is one of my favorite jokes ever
from Beth I wish that shotgun was my
penis if it were you could call me
Ernest Hemingway I don't get it and I
don't need to now considering the writer
Hemingway killed himself by putting a
shotgun in his mouth you could probably
guess what she was going for the next
episode is raising gazorpazorp which
opens are the pretty great miserable
joke the family debates over whether to
intervene with more tea humping his sex
robot upstairs but then something goes
wrong um Rick could you come with me
please quickly okay now if we hear
squeaking we intervene and I love to
call back in the next scene also in this
episode these steps on the female
absorbers are reports say sis semper
calumny 'm which is latin for you're
always wrong and summer says this to
defend herself and if you think my top
is cute you cannot execute this is a
reference to Johnny Cochran's famous
defense in the OJ Simpson trial if it
doesn't fit you must acquit then at the
end of this episode Morty juniors angry
dance is a reference to Kevin Bacon's
angry dance and Footloose now the next
episode is rixty minutes aka the first
interdimensional cable episode and for
this episode many of the shows that they
watched were improvised by Justin
roiland in the audio booth that's why
you can hear him breaking character a
few times i'm gazorpazorp infield [ __ ]
now give me my in enchilada called
two brothers two brothers it's just
Cooper I also love where the camera
flashes past a channel with a music
video of Michael Jackson's Thriller with
phone people so this is the phone
universe
close Rick counters of the Rick time on
the next episode something wicked this
way comes has a bunch of little Easter
eggs that you probably already spotted
to things like Adventure Time and
Stephen King and Steven jobs but the one
that I only now just caught was in the
closing X gonna give it to you montage
the bully that they beat up in the
schoolyard is a grown up version of the
character Randal from the show recess
okay moving on to close Rick counters of
the Rick kind which introduces us to all
the other Rick's and Morty's from
different universes so for example in
the background of the Citadel there's a
Cronenberg Rick and Cronenberg Morty
presumably from their c-137 universe
that got Cronenberg I also like the joke
here when the Rick's examine Rick's
portal gun oh come on don't look at
another man's portal gun history we all
go to weird places now of course this is
a reference to the universal anxiety of
someone looking at all the porn an area
that's search history but if you think
about this is hilarious because this is
how Rick looks at the universe is just
surfing through different porn websites
and getting off okay now up next are two
of the craziest visual gags in this
entire series so first up I mentioned
gravity falls earlier and a big
reference comes in this episode so when
the Rick's are chasing our Rick and
Morty through the portals if you look
closely a few random objects fly out of
this one it turns out that is the same
mug and other belongings of grunkle Stan
from an episode of gravity falls when he
loses them in a portal in I'll get to
that second crazy visual gag in a second
but first I want to thank quid for
sponsoring this video quid is an awesome
new app where you can collect great
stickers and cards and 3d figures for
free all on your phone so if you use
emojis and stickers when you text your
friends like I do who it has thousands
of free stickers that you can't find
anywhere else from great shows like Rick
and Morty and Adventure Time and Bob's
Burgers Steven universe our Puff Girls
and Family Guy and cold hits like
Breaking Bad in Star Trek and games like
five nights at Freddy's and hey look at
me you can drag and drop these stickers
on iMessage like when you're chatting
with your buddy and he's pressuring you
to punchy's going an adventure that
you're just not ready for and if you
collect Funko pop figures quid has those
too actually we're gonna do a giveaway
where if you share this video on Twitter
with the hashtag
new Rick stars will pip you adorable
poopy buttholes and send you a Funko pop
vinyl Rick and Morty figure yeah get on
this e-cigs are awesome now some of
these stickers cards and toys on QuIDD
are super rare and hard to get so good
luck but the good news is that you can
meet cool people on quit look at their
collections and trade with them just as
easily and as quick as chatting with
each other and as a new feature you can
showcase your collection by adding
stickers to images you already have on
your camera roll including a new pack of
new rock stars themed stickers like our
lightning bolt and then red arrows and
circles so you know when something's
really important just please don't put
any of those circles or arrows around my
nipples you're already doing it I know
you're doing it why did I say it was it
thinking just check out the profile tab
on iOS new stickers cards and figures
that again you can collect for free are
released every day and I hear that
they're gonna drop a new collection for
a property that I'm just saying if you'd
like this channel you're gonna want to
get it on just click on the link in the
description and follow us on QuIDD our
username is new rock stars anna says a
friend you can trade with us that's come
on let's get closer and be more than
friends I think we're ready yeah yeah
okay so back to this episode the other
crazy visual gag comes in this awesome
montage with Rick and Morty running
through various alternate dimensions of
chairs and pizzas and phones and if you
look closely the background you can see
the framed portraits are changing as
well but the one that blew my mind is
that later in this chair universe Rick
and Morty pass a homeless chair who
drinks out of a bottle that shaped like
a tiny bus and then immediately after
the bus that passes Rick and Morty is in
the shape of a waddle this attention to
detail is insane also later in this
episode doofus Rick tells Jerry about
eric stoltz mask morty and this
reference to eric stoltz is a subtle nod
to Rick and Morty's origin as Justin
roiland animated Back to the Future
parody short called doc and Marty which
he had to change for legal reasons to
Rick and Morty and a little history on
Back to the Future here the part of
Marty McFly was originally played by
actor Eric Stoltz before he got replaced
by Michael J Fox because they wanted the
character to be a bit more comedic so
the season 1 finale is Rick see business
with the house party so Rick tells
summer that her improvised nonsense word
of glipglop
is a hate word
clip gloves from the third dimension
going to come over and play cards or
something
clip-clop you're lucky at trap floor key
and doesn't hear you say that it's like
the N word and the C word had a baby and
it was raised by all the bad words for
Jews then later Rick totally
appropriates this hate word yeah and one
of the guests at this house party is a
staircase person from the tavern in the
meeseeks and destroy' episode now I love
the character of a brutal Winkler all of
his lines stem from the fact that he's
half Lincoln half Hitler and this one's
my favorite they're to be emancipated
from her own inferior genes and later
this episode rick grinds up the crystal
kalaxian and snorts it leading them to
this choreographed dance and then when
Morty angrily throws a crystal outside
the interdimensional monster snatches
that meets it and exactly after that you
can see the creature also happily doing
though Rick danced in the background
there's also this really dirty joke from
Tammy I love watching [ __ ] I mean I
don't know if I personally would ever do
it okay so kids cover your ears but
[ __ ] is a Japanese term for a sexual
act that involves lots of men doing
something to one woman or man and then
later in this episode Tammy flirts with
bird person I'm not looking to get into
a soul bond
I'm just looking for I believe bird
person can arrange that oh it sounds
like bird person is planning a [ __ ] I
don't even know how you would begin
doing it okay moving on to season two
the season 2 premiere is a ricky'll in
time which opens with this great meta
joke man that guy is the red grin
grumble - pretending he knows what's
going on well guess what I made him up
you really are your father's children
think for yourselves don't be sheep so
Rick is basically making fun of all the
young fans of this show who laugh along
the references that they don't
understand like [ __ ] I hope you don't
understand what that is and the next
episode of season 2 is Morty Knight run
with the character of fart voiced by
Jemaine Clement and I really appreciated
this subtle joke I communicate through
what you call Jessica's feet no
telepathy just be clear fart is reading
Morty's mind here which is yeah
currently thinking about his crush
Jessica's feet so the song that fart
sings is goodbye moon man
and Jemaine Clement is invoking David
Bowie he actually did a Bowie parody on
his show Flight of the Conchords also in
this episode in the arcade blitz and
chips there's a cameo by mr. meeseeks in
the background
he's helping another alien win a pinball
game and then when he successful mr.
meeseeks vanishes we also see the Jerry
daycare center
where the music that's being played is
human music which is the same song from
Jerry's simulation back in season one
and night some aliens and now human
music I like thank you the next episode
is autoerotic
assimilation and the title itself is an
amazing pun it's also a reference to
another sex act which is a callback to
what Mordy and Jessica walked in on
squanch to him in the previous season
finale now this is the episode with
unity that's Rick's ex-lover whose
consciousness took over an entire planet
my favorite joke here is a reference to
Dan Harmon's previous TV series
community so notice how Rick's watching
TV he's playing God forcing the
characters to have sex on the table and
then canceling and uncounseled in the
show which are both things that happen
on community pay the next episode total
Rick Hall is another favorite of mine
from the series the concept of a
parasite that creates false positive
memories it's just so ingenious and one
mystery here is how this parasite made
it into the house in the first place
remember Rick accuses summer somebody
probably tracked it in last week on the
bottom of their shoe or on a piece of
alien fruit get off the high road summer
we all got pinkeye because you won't
stop texting on the toilet if you look
closely at this there's actually a
little digital call back that answers
this mystery early in the episode Rick
throws out these green rocks and he got
those rocks back and Morty night run and
notice how they have these little pink
warts on them these are the same pink
warts that are on the parasite corpses
so really it was Rick that tracked in
the parasite from the beginning and one
thing that you might have caught is that
Mister poopy butthole was edited into
the opening credits partly to tease this
idea of false memories changing our view
of the past but also this makes sense
because these clips in the opening
sequence are horrifying negative
memories proving that mr. poopy butthole
is actually real now in this episode
Rick talks about how he hoards a supply
of limited-edition Nintendo
three DSS which Justin roiland actually
said is something he did in real life
hoping that he'd be able to catch in on
him Sunday but one little clever joke
that I liked in this episode came from
Frankenstein admitting he was wrong to
gang up on summer I was on the wrong
side of the pitchfork on this one I'm
not even gonna explain that one this is
great so after this episode is get
schwifty which includes an animated
cameo by justin roiland he's the guy
being sacrificed to the head god with
sign saying thief and in this episode's
amazing post-credits scene nice cheese
transformed back into water tea and he
attacks the numeric cons shooting the
number 6 & 7 which is a reference to
tech nines albums sixes and sevens the
next episode is the Rick's must be crazy
where Rick and Morty go into the
different layers of the micro versus
leap who's voiced by Stephen Colbert
says this I dropped out of school it's
not a place for smart people
now this detail is meant to parallel the
character to Rick who said pretty much
the same thing back in the first pilot
episode but I'll tell you tell you how I
feel about school Jeri it's a waste of
time there's also this little joke when
Rick remembers that he screwed around
with the society in the Microverse you
told me it means much obliged and then
this gets called back later this episode
much obliged I also appreciated in this
episode how Rick uses the same hidden
snake tricks that he used and get
schwifty to make the president think you
can turn people into snakes okay it's
gonna be past big trouble in little
Sanchez to the second interdimensional
cable episode the little bits commercial
in this episode when the guy swears in
front of children one of the kids looks
up at him and shoots him a dirty look
now the next episode is the purge
episode look who's purging now where
summer blows a hole in the garage roof
which gets called back in the following
episode when the hole appears freshly
patched in the opening an establishing
shot now that brings us to in even 50
but I'm having fun let's keep going into
season three now i already did a
breakdown the first episode of season 3
so definitely go check that out i
already pointed out a few great missable
jokes at first there was the memory of
Rick in the background as he reacts to
911 footage fine
I'm driving
morty also alludes to finding jerry's
mannequin leg which is a reference to a
video that dan harmon made that showed
him humping a mannequin leg in his bed
there's also a few Easter eggs for
gravity falls like there's a mabel morty
and a dipper morty there's also a quick
frame it shows the outline of bricks
penis but there were three other things
that i didn't point out in this episode
first in the garage there's a framed
picture of doofus rick in the cabinet
that presumably belongs to jerry who
remember got along with him so well in
that season one episode clearly he
misses him so much and then also in the
false memory that rick created of his
origin story his 1998 house is a
recreation of walter white's house in
the show Breaking Bad notice how the
house layout and architecture and even
the bushes in the front yard are exactly
the same this makes sense because like
Heisenberg this version of Rick is a
kind-hearted family man who ends up
using his scientific brilliance for evil
purposes
and then finally season three showed us
a new end car to the episode that
usually shows Dan Harmon's production
company logo before it was claymation
that showed Harmon with his white
happily watching TV but now this one
shows Harmon after his divorce alone on
the couch probably drunk depressing and
hilarious now again there are lots of
things I didn't cover on this list and a
lot of it are just references and jokes
that I found a little obvious but I'm
curious what do you think I missed
learns it being a lot I kind of want to
make a second follow-up video to this
with even more jokes and references but
come on hit me up in the comments let's
give each other even more reasons to
laugh at this show show me what you got
and subscribe to new rockstars so you
can watch any other Rick and Morty
videos we make and you can help Rick and
Maury a bigger priority for us by liking
this video and sharing it and tweet
about it and keep a link to the video in
your tweet you can also be a bigger part
of new rockstars by contributing to us
on patreon big thanks to all of our
current donors especially BM havoc you
can tweet me your favorite Rick and
Morty jokes at EA vas or follow new
rockstars on Twitter at new rockstars
for updates on our videos bye